sollte sich
dieses Video anschauen,
denn heute erkläre
ich nachweislich,
warum wir inteligenter
sind als unsere Eltern.
Der moderen Mensch macht
gerade eine seltsame Evolution.
Seit Beginn des 20. Jahrhunderts
wird er fortgehend schlauer.
Die Werte professionell
durchgeführter IQ-Test
steigt aktuell um
etwa 0,3 Punkte pro Jahr.
Kinder übertreffen ihre Eltern
im Schnitt um 10 Punkte im IQ-Test.
Dieses Phänomen
nennt man den Flynn-Effekt.
Benannt nach
dem Politologen James Flynn.
IQ-Tests werden von Experten
als eines der
besten diagnostischen Instrumente
der Psychologie angesehen,
auf deren Ergebnisse
man sich verlassen kann,
vorausgesetzt,
sie werden fachkundig ausgewertet.
Wenn die Tests also stimmen, woher
kommt das stetige Steigen des IQs?
Bevor wir das klären,
müssen wir festhalten,
was der IQ eigentlich ist
Der Intelligenzquotient ist kein
absoluter Wert, sondern immer
ein Bezugswert im Vergleich
zur Gesamt-Bevölkerung.
So sieht die IQ-Verteilung
immer aus. Eine Glockenkurve.
Wir haben es hier mit
einer Normalverteilung zu tun.
Der Großteil der Menschen
liegt in der Mitte, und die ist 100.
Sehr wenige Menschen, knapp 2,5 %,
sind entweder hochbegabt
oder IQ-Größe 130 oder geistig
behindert, sprich IQ kleiner 70.
Deswegen muss
die Justierung der IQ-Verteilung
immer neu vorgenommen werden.
Aber da die Verteilung immer gleich
aussieht, hat es eine Zeit gedauert,
bis James Flynn
die Entdeckung machte,
dass ein IQ von
100 heute viel höher liegt
als ein IQ
von 100 im Jahre 1900.
Im Vergleich zu der Menschheit 1900
hätten wir nach damaligem Standard
einen Durchschnitts-IQ von 130, wir
wären damals alle hochbegabt gewesen.
Bzw. die Menschen der Zeit
hätten nach heutigem Standard
einen Durchschnitts-IQ von 70,
heißt, sie wären im
Schnitt geistig behindert.
Wie kann das sein?
Naja, normale Intelligenztests
bestehen aus verschiedenen Segmenten,
wo verschiedene
Skills getestet werden,
und nicht in allen Segmenten
verbessern sich die Menschen stetig.
In den Kategorien
Rechnen oder Wortschatz
bleiben die Ergebnisse über die
Generationen ziemlich konstant.
Die stetige Verbesserung
des Gesamtergebnisses
ist fast ausschließlich auf bestimmte
Teile des IQ-Tests zurückzuführen,
die auf diese 3 Skills abzielen:
1. Klassifizierung.
2. Abstraktes Denken.
3. Hypothetisches Denken.
Schauen wir uns an,
was das genau bedeutet:
Die Fähigkeit zur Klassifizierung
taucht in Intelligenztest so auf:
Was haben
Äpfel und Orangen gemeinsam?
Der Psychologe Alexander
Lurija führte in den 20er Jahren
sehr interessante Befragungen
mit russischen Bauern durch.
Er fragte z.B.,
was haben Fisch und Krähe gemeinsam?
Heute würden wir zumindest sagen,
es sind beides Tiere,
aber für die Menschen
damals hatten Fisch und Krähen
gar nichts gemeinsam,
weil die Menschen
vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
noch anderes gedacht haben.
Früher bezog man sein Denken die
Gegenstände der Umwelt immer auf sich
und den konkreten
Nutzen für einen selbst.
Bei Fischen dachten die Bauern an
Tiere, die man fangen und essen kann,
bei Krähen dachten sie an Wesen,
mit denen sie nichts anfangen können.
Die Bauern waren nicht dümmer,
sondern extrem pragmatisch.
Doch dieses nutzenbezogene Denken
hat sich im Laufe des 20.
Jahrhunderts ganz stark gewandelt.
Die zweite wichtige Sache:
Abstraktes Denken.
Davon verlangt die
moderne Welt immer mehr.
Unsere Omas und Opas
haben z.B. ein Problem damit,
dass Knöpfe heute gar keine
mechanischen Knöpfe mehr sein müssen,
sondern vielleicht nur
ein Icon auf dem Schirm.
Für einen Digital-Native
hingegen ist es klar,
dass es eine Art von
An- und Ausknopf geben muss,
der aber
völlig verschieden aussehen kann.
Auch die Bildung hat sich verändert.
Schaut man sich Schultests
in den USA aus dem Jahre 1910 an,
dann gab es Fragen wie,
was ist die Hauptstadt von Ohio?
1990 sieht das schon ganz anders aus.
Z.B. warum ist die größte Stadt eines
Staates selten die Hauptstadt?
Bei
Intelligenztests prüft man auch,
ob jemand in der Lage ist,
logische Analogien zu ziehen.
Z.B. "essen" verhält sich zu
"hungrig" wie "trinken" zu "durstig".
Easy, richtig.
Im Jahr 1900 war das auch noch easy.
Jetzt werden wir etwas abstrakter:
Schaut euch diese zwei Reihen an.
Wenn ihr die 2. Reihe logisch und
analog zur 1. Reihe beenden müsstet,
was müsste dann dort stehen?
Richtig, ein Halbkreis.
Denn ein Dreick
ist ein halbes Quadrat,
und ein Halbkreis
ist ein halber Kreis.
Während die Leute in 1900 noch
Probleme mit dieser Aufgabe hatten,
war es 1960 kein Problem mehr.
Gehen wir in das Jahr 2010,
wir werden noch abstrakter.
Wir haben jetzt
Kreis, Kreis, Halbkreis,
und drunter steht 16, 16, "?".
Die meisten College-Studenten
setzten hier die 8 ein.
8 ist die Hälfte von 16.
Und ein Halbkreis ist
die Hälfte von einem Kreis.
1960 hätten die Meisten
damit noch Probleme gehabt.
Was uns heute also
leichter fällt als früher,
ist, auf einem
ganz abstrakten Level
zwischen Formen-
und Zahlen eine Logik anzuwenden.
Kommen wir zum letzten
wichtigen Skill im Flynn-Effekt.
Gehen wir zurück zu Lurija und seiner
Befragung der russischen Bauern.
Er sagte zu ihnen: Da, wo immer
Schnee liegt, sind Bären immer weiß.
Am Nordpol liegt immer Schnee.
Welche Farben haben die Bären dort?
Die Bauern wussten damals gar nichts
mit dieser hypothetischen
Frage anzufangen.
Sie antworteten einfach,
sie hätten noch nie etwas anderes
als einen braunen Bären gesehen.
Es hat nichts mit Dummheit zu tun.
Sie waren durchaus in
der Lage, logisch zu denken.
Sie waren nur nicht bereit,
logisches Denken
auf hypothetische
Fragestellungen anzuwenden.
Wenn ich heute sage,
wo es immer Bonbons regnet,
sind die Bären
immer blau gestreift.
Im Takatuka-Land
regnet es immer Bonbons,
welche Farben
haben die Bären dort?
Dann würde jeder
sagen, blau gestreift.
So wie wir heute denken,
steht die Logik im Vordergrund.
Damit, dass es
keine Bonbons regnet,
und dass es keine
gestreiften Bären gibt,
damit haben wir
heute kein Problem mehr.
Und wenn jemand glaubt, dass
die russischen Bauern dumm sind,
mit ihrer Beschränktheit
auf die braunen Bären,
so was passiert
heute immer noch.
Vor Kurzem
habe ich ein Video gemacht,
über autonomes Fahren
und moralische Dilemma.
Wenn ein selbstfahrendes
Auto in die Situation käme,
dass es entweder ein kleines
Kind oder eine Oma umfahren müsste,
und auch noch
technisch in der Lage wäre,
zwischen dem kleinen Kind
und der Oma zu unterscheiden,
wie sollte es programmiert sein?
In wen sollte es reinfahren?
Und ganz viele
der Kommentare waren so etwas wie:
Das ist eine total dumme Frage,
weil es dazu niemals kommen würde.
Es geht also gar nicht darum, wer
schlauer und wer weniger schlau ist,
sondern, wer mehr
oder weniger dazu bereit ist,
hypothetische,
wenn auch unrealistische
oder absurde Situationen
trotzdem logisch durchzudenken.
Ich möchte hier auf
auf James Flynn verweisen,
wo er selbst über seine
Entdeckungen spricht,
habe ich euch unten verlinkt.
Er spricht über
die 60er Jahre, wo er Student war,
über Martin Luther King und darüber,
wie er mit seinem
Großvater in Streit geriet,
welcher der Meinung war,
dass schwarze Menschen
eher minderwertig sind,
und er sagte zu ihm:
Was würdest du machen,
wenn du morgen aufwachen würdest
und plötzlich schwarz wärst?
Seine Großvater sagte:
Das ist die dümmste Frage,
die ich je gehört habe.
Er konnte nichts damit anfangen,
weil es ja nie passieren würde.
Wir sehen also, dass die Bereitschaft
zum logischen Durchdenken
von hypothetischen Situationen
gerade für moralische
und gesellschaftliche
Debatten wichtig ist.
Das heißt auch,
dass gesellschaftliche Debatten
heute schneller
eskalieren, weil uns da,
was wäre wenn,
so wichtig geworden ist.
Aber wären wir nicht bereit,
Hypothesen ernst zu nehmen,
selbst wenn sie nicht möglich sind,
wären wir nicht dazu bereit,
uns um das "Was-wäre-wenn"
Gedanken zu machen,
statt ganz
pragmatisch um das, was ist,
würden wir uns viel
langsamer weiterentwickeln.
Forschung und
Wissenschaft sind nichts anderes,
als Hypothesen aufzustellen
und denen mit Logik nachzugehen.
Hochintelligente Menschen, wie
z.B. Elon Musk, sind oft Spinner,
weil sie Spaß am Hypothetischen,
am Unmöglichen, haben,
weswegen er gerade versucht,
den Mars zu besiedeln.
Also, wir werden immer
schlauer auf dem Papier
und unsere IQ-Werte steigen stetig.
Das ist aber nur auf
diese 3 Skills zurückzuführen.
Experten glauben, dass der
Fynn-Effekt lange nicht vorbei ist
und zumindest noch dieses
Jahrhundert weiterlaufen wird.
D.h., dass auch
wir unseren Enkelkindern
irgendwann
nicht mehr folgen können.
Intelligenz ist also viel mehr
als nur eine Zahl aus einem IQ-Test.
Ich wünsche mir
manchmal den Pragmatismus
unserer Vorfahren zurück, denn am
Ende ist es am wichtigsten,
was wir mit unserer
Intelligenz anstellen.
Schönschlau.
Was sind eure
Gedanken zum Flynn-Effekt?
Schreibt eure Kommentare
zusammen mit euren Fragen.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.